this is the Jocko underground podcast
with Echo Charles me Jocko willink and
okay we we are
a part of society no way to get around
that right even if you're even if you're
living out in the middle of nowhere you
are gonna have to brush up against
Society
so we've got this thing going on right
now probably at a scale that's never
gone on before
in my opinion and that is the world of
advertising right now just constantly
to
capitalize on human beings desire for
immediate gratification and
what can we do
to protect ourselves
our friends the people we know
against this onslaught of
just
onslaught of uh advertising and and
attention seeking yeah
that's out there for us
I'm gonna go ahead and start off uh this
is one of those tell us the story for
the 474th time about the book
mind games oh yeah mind games and how it
made you feel like you shouldn't lose
your temper and the kind of trick you
paid it played on yourself because I
think this is a similar thing yeah okay
uh my name's Mike Powell by the way is
the author so it's not a book like what
you'd think just to clarify it's not
like this
it's like a book with these teeny tiny
short chapters that are some are just
little puzzles some are this and then
some are little explanation stuff anyway
one of them was anger management or
losing your attempt or something like
that I forget Which chapter was but it
was about anger management and in there
it said a lot of things but one of the
main things was that Ang like people
with a short temper or get people who
get angry really easily
usually comes from low self-esteem in
that and that that was always like a
shameful thing growing up just you know
in school they teach you self-esteem or
whatever and I always thought to myself
how can someone have low self-esteem
it's kind of embarrassing to like have a
low selfish steam I didn't even know
really what it was it just sounded real
bad so for whatever reason that was
ingrained in me where it's like you if
you can avoid
displaying that you have low self-esteem
you should avoid that I've always
thought that or whatever so yeah when it
said that I was like Han it made sense
too and then you used to have a bad
temper no never I never had a bad temper
you used to get angry used to show anger
yeah more Loosely so I mean no that's
why was this a big deal because it said
the word self-esteem so it's so to me I
overkilled it and I was like anytime you
get angry you just have low self-esteem
and I went back to work just preaching
it preaching it to everybody like all
the bouncers or whatever like where it's
like yeah man if you get and think about
it because they explain it it doesn't
just say that and then move on it
explains everything whatever I'm talking
about controlling your environment Iron
Man and like all this stuff right so it
just hit me real hard and to me I took
it as hey if you get mad even though it
says in there anger is a natural part of
life you know all this stuff it I took
it as like yeah if you get mad and
openly display you're angry you have low
self-esteem that's how it landed on my
brain you the way you've told me that
story before is like you played a trick
on yourself of like oh if I get angry
that means I have low self-esteem and
I'm not gonna be that good exactly right
so I think here this is an opportunity
for us to play a trick on ourselves
kinds of or use that same methodology to
say oh
if I'm actually
allowing this stuff to influence me I
have a weak mind yeah right like that
that's what it is if you can't get off
your phone if you can't put down the
stop scrolling if you can't do that your
freaking mind is weak and it's being
invaded it's being invaded by someone
that's smarter and stronger than you and
it's taking advantage of your weakness
playing you for a sucker as we used to
say
failure so I think that's what you got
to do you got to take a step back you
got to recognize what's happening and
you got to realize
you can't let it happen you've got to
get some control back and not allow
these uh I mean to me when we talk about
advertising we're just talking about
social media now I mean have have you
ever watched a show in the last well
when's the last time you watched a show
where you had to watch a commercial like
the Super Bowl maybe yeah right because
everyone does streaming or on demand so
it's not like the old days where you're
kind of subjected when I was a little
kid you were subjected to advertisements
because you were watching a show you're
freaking addicted to that little TV set
Saturday morning cartoons and they're
gonna play the whatever advertisement on
there to get you to buy whatever but it
was you it was involuntary yeah you were
subjected to it now
I mean I even have YouTube red or
YouTube premium premium sure and when I
when I go on someone that doesn't have
YouTube premium I get mad brutal like I
I think I don't get mad but I think
you're you're this is ridiculous I think
YouTube premium is 10 bucks a month
actually I think it was 9.99 when I
signed but they jacked that price up now
it's like 13 bucks now but so I'm not
even subjected to advertisements on
YouTube by the way that's amazing we
have no advertisements on YouTube people
it's when I when I suffer through
someone else's YouTube right now yeah
and they click on a video to watch it
they gotta watch a 30 second ad or
whatever I think what are you doing what
a waste of time
dude what are you doing so I'm not
subjected to it there so so really the
place you get subjected to it is social
media and you click on this thing or the
thing pops up and it just happens to be
algorithmically connected to something
that you searched yesterday and it's
just isn't that strange you'll search
for something and then it just pops up
all day long oh yeah related stuff too
so what do you need to do detach take a
step back see that you're being tricked
and don't allow yourself to be tricked
that's the way I look at it yep straight
up trick and here's the thing I mean
good thank you for that advice
but as Mo like most things bro it's it
goes deep it goes deep and it goes so
deep that it's not all bad like
appropriate advertising is good for you
and your goals like if I want to if you
like watching YouTube commercials
sometimes yeah you've got issues I like
sometimes watching my daughter's the
same way where well here's the thing and
then that's another trick too by the way
but it's not a trick against me it's a
trick for me in a way where if you
notice commercials now are like they're
fun to watch like they're clever
commercials it's not like old school
back in the day commercials where it's
like oh freaking buy this you know yeah
but it's different now now they're
entertaining now they got celebrities in
there now they got jokes now they got
humor they got special effects they got
like bro it's entertaining commercials
are entertaining that's not right now
that you're talking about your own
commercials for Jocko fuel sometimes
I'm just saying that's part of the game
now entertaining commercial stuff which
you
[Music]
that's how it is nowadays and then I
don't what is the advertising versus
um I like watching your commercials
assistant director the the I don't know
if there's a there is a difference
advertising and marketing I don't know
what's what but nonetheless we'll just I
don't know okay dogs over here not in
his head like you disrupted different
right yeah
um I don't know the difference so let's
just say marketing because really that's
kind of essentially what we're talking
about where and there it's ever certain
actual advertisement will be played on
this and there and you click here and
whatever that's an actual advertisement
but marketing is freaking deep and it
goes super deep so like if you if I see
you wearing a XYZ shirt and I like you
and I look up to you you just marketed
that XYZ shirt to me
even though you just wore it because it
was comfortable and you didn't even know
anyone was gonna see you that day but
that's marketing already because it
influenced me to think to see value in
that shirt because I look up to you if
it's good enough for you it's damn for
sure good enough for me you see what I'm
saying effective marketing right there
and that's just like a branding kind of
situation but you can go like um look if
I'm looking for freaking uh books on how
to improve my freaking archery right and
one is like talking about the trigger or
I don't know I'm just making up these
terms
inside of bow and arrow the other day
anyway
and I find a book and I'm like cool this
is a good one and then I go online again
and it shows me another book because I
it obviously the algorithm you know
determined that I'm obviously looking
for books to improve my archery it's
going to show me another one that helps
me with my goal like it helps me
so advertising can help of course the
companies that are advertising whatever
but it helps me too so you got to kind
of discern like what's helping me and
what's just luring me and using me as a
pawn overall you know so it's like yeah
how you said like yeah it plays off your
immediate gratification sure yes it does
and those are the ones you want to like
avoid you know how they they'll get the
perfectly manicured hamburger with the
glistening and a CGI by the way it's not
even a real hamburger it's like a
computer hamburger but it looks so good
you know and they'll show it to you at a
certain time you know like right before
lunch 11 A.M something like this because
they know they know lunch is coming up
see I'm saying
or they'll put certain colors on certain
um advertisements that like
proven apparently I don't know but
apparently they're proven to make you
more hungry like I guess red and yellow
it's like makes you more like tiger
stripe
no bro no red and yellow apparently
makes you more hungry bro that's what I
heard nonetheless it goes deep but I'm
saying it's an advertising is not all
bad that's the hard part
so you got to navigate
I think you should definitely uh set up
some filters in your brain yeah and try
not to click on things that's what I'm
saying yeah but yours is super simple
because you're like function straight up
yeah anything after that is all extra
credit I was looking at one of my kid my
kids grams sure and they had
advertisements every third or fourth
scroll
you know what I'm saying so every third
or fourth thing that they would scroll
past was an advertisement and that was
on you when you said your kids that was
that was on my daughter's phone okay and
I was I was like uh
damn because I don't have barely any
advertisements on mine barely any I
wonder why that is I think it's because
I never click on anything I don't click
like I don't like anybody's thing huh I
don't share anything I'm just like I'm
like a a damn Monk on Instagram
Instagram okay I'm not sending out them
little hearts yeah and I think that must
be have what it must have something to
do with it yeah I would imagine so
because yeah that's true because all
like how how many advertisements do you
get like
I'm not bombarded with them but they're
part of my experience every single time
for sure I'm actually surprised when I
see one I'll be like oh there's one oh
what's that oh it's a sponsored thing
and because it always looks weird to me
anyways because it's something that I'm
not it I think the algorithm has a hard
time figuring me out anyways it sort of
doesn't know what to send my way yeah
because it would make sense and I don't
know how these algorithms work
specifically but it would make sense
where like you know how you're scrolling
you know and after a while like
especially when you're not like oh all
into it you're just scrolling for
something that really catches your eye
for whatever reason so I wonder if it
has to be monitoring how much it like
and then you pause once yeah it monitors
all that stuff every little move you
make it's modern and I wish I could
think of this I I clicked on a YouTube
video the other day and you got to
remember for me that's nothing no
investment whatsoever because I don't
have to watch an advertisement right so
I clicked on a YouTube video and it was
something so stupid I can't remember
what it is but the freaking top
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it cost eight
dollars and 18 cents a month and if you
can't afford to support us we can still
support you just email assistance Jocko
underground.com and we'll get you taken
care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground